passionne ministre la parole est à
monsieur jacques alain bénisti merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'éducation nationale madame la ministre
en 2012
votre majorité a pris une grave décision
dont vous aviez mal estimé les
conséquences
cette décision c'est celle de supprimer
une aide personnalisée en primaire sur
les deux heures pratiqué auparavant pour
tous les élèves qui étaient en situation
de décrochage scolaire
trois ans plus tard les inévitables
résultats sont là plus de 20% des élèves
arrivant au collège sont en situation
d'échec scolaire et cela essentiellement
due à un manque de soutien en primaire
certes pour vous rattraper mais nous on
arrivait en anglais par décret un
ensemble de mesures pour le collège
pourrait s'y essayer de rectifier le tir
mais malheureusement pour vous
l'unicef vient de pointer du doigt cette
incohérence dans un rapport publié hier
notre pays est reléguée dans les
derniers rangs des pays européens avec
plus de 140 mille élèves en situation de
décrochage
donc madame la milice ma question reste
simple allez vous continuer la motion
s'il vous plaît allez vous continuer un
avocat vous obstinez à nous imposer sans
débat une réforme du collège qu'il a
comme seule ambition que de colmater en
aval
c'est incohérent ces dysfonctionnements
allez vous continuer à ne poser que des
pansements homéo m homéopathiques
au lieu de prendre à bras le corps les
véritables décisions à partir des causes
du décrochage scolaire en primaire il y
a madame la ministre de l'intérêt de
toute la nation pour l'éducation de nos
enfants
la parole est à madame najat vallaud
belkacem ministre de l'éducation
nationale de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
si monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
bénisti vous me voyez ravi sincèrement
de vous entendre faire allusion au
rapport de l'unicef qui pointe avec
beaucoup de justesse cette réalité
terrible de la pauvreté des enfants
un enfant sur cinq nous rappelle-t-il et
je déplore je déplore une chose c'est
que ces enfants en situation de pauvreté
soit si absente de nos débats publics
concernant l'école comme si on s'était
habitué petit à petit à leur sort comme
si on s'était habitué à avoir un système
scolaire qui lui même est inégalitaire
allant je veux rappeler ici puisque vous
me invité monsieur bénisti que tout
l'objet des réformes que nous
entreprenons en matière éducative depuis
2012 c'est précisément de redonner à
chacun de ses enfants les véritables
moyens de la réussite
lorsque nous réintroduisons pas prêt
scolarisation des enfants avant l'âge de
trois ans là où vous l'aviez
complètement saborder c'est précisément
pour redonner l'acquisition du
vocabulaire et du langage à des enfants
placés en situation difficile l'an que
nous mettons en place le dispositif plus
de maîtres queux de classe à l'école
primaire je ne vous parle même pas du
collage il viendrait à l'école primaire
plus de maîtres queux de classe ça sert
à quoi ça sert à mieux accompagner les
enfants notamment pour qu'ils acquièrent
les fondamentaux dont vous venez de me
parler lorsque nous réformons
l'éducation prioritaire en mettant 300
millions d'euros de plus sur les
établissements les plus en difficulté
sociale c'est précisément pour aider ces
mêmes enfants auxquels vous faites
allusion
lorsque enfin nous faisons la réforme du
collège je le redis ici ça n'est pas
pour porter atteinte aux disciplines
fondamentales c'est au contraire pour
qu'elle soit mieux à priser mieux
acquises par les élèves par d'autres
pratiques pédagogiques de
l'accompagnement personnalisé de
l'interdisciplinarité qui ont fait leurs
preuves ailleurs
alors monsieur le député puisque vous
êtes si attaché à la réussite de tous
les enfants de france je vous invite à
nous accompagner dans nos réformes et à
commencer par recréer des postes dans
l'enseignement comme nous le faisons et
redonner de la formation aux maîtres
dont vous avez oublié de préciser que
vous l'aviez supprimés
merci madame la ministre la séance des
questions au gouvernement
la séance des questions au gouvernement
et terminer la séance est suspendue